ich weiß nicht warum was fühlt sich
mittlerweile schon hier einfach von
meiner kamera richtig komisch an keine
maske auf zu haben
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einer
neuen episode what the hell is aufm
einem kanal ich würde sagen gefangen mit
dem ersten vers der von sandra wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin ich würde mich am
liebsten auch bei germany's next
topmodel anmelden und die zeiten als die
zeit nehmen ja
nein nächste wort fällt stand ebenfalls
von sander und zwar heute mittag in
unserem ortsgruppe gefragte leute glaubt
ich soll heute abend schon nach köln
wegen schneesturm ab heute abend soll
krass werden würde schon jetzt fahren
aber die essen abends schaschlik dann
würde ich bleiben oder auch bleiben dann
ja schon argument ist so herzlich
willkommen in sandersleben sie letztlich
leiten von ihrem magen ein kumpel von
mir herzlich gestern den arm gebrochen
und wie geht es ihm ganz gut hat mir
heute erstmal eine schokolade
mitgebracht und gesagt hätte breivik
kitkat vollidioten
echt comedypreis mal verleihen bin
gerade mit dem postboten
zusammengestoßen und ich wuchs er nein
dhl
ich habe heute ein kostenloses schnitzel
bekommen wieso das kommt auf die police
noch was drauf ja sie können entscheiden
ist das denn kostenlos ja natürlich das
schnitzel bitte ich glaube das geht
jetzt das ganze video hier so weiter ich
standen alle auf ein mädchen ich auch
auf denen auf lisa sie hat die ganze
zeit geschrieben ich glaube das hat weh
als ich auf ihrem vorstand habe wer hat
euch verarscht mann der kontrolle hat in
der bahn nach meine fahrkarte gefragt
und dann bin ich erstmal weg gelaufen er
hat mich durch den halben zu verfolgt
was ist dann passiert na ja er war
stinksauer weil ich eine fahrkarte hatte
becker warum läufst du denn
farkas mein opa ist der beste wieso er
doppelpunkt nach dem essen sollst du
ruhen eine stunde gar nichts tun nachdem
ruhen nicht vergessen wieder etwas essen
mein opa 84 sehr weise das stimmt ich
habe gestern einfach mir selber gekocht
und das fand ich so lecker dass sich das
aufgegessen habe ich mir diesen genau
das gleiche noch mal gekocht ja jetzt
ist die waage kaputt ich war gerade aus
unterwegs das ist doch nicht lustig doch
und kind auf den boden gespuckt die
mutter meinte wir spucken nicht was im
mund ist wird geschluckt der vater zieht
die augenbrauen hoch
mutter sagt kein wort jetzt das ist
lustig weil das versteht man nur wenn
man in meinem bett es ist 65 ich schlafe
fünf minuten ist 38 in der schule
es ist 19 45 minuten es ist 19 ist so
man kennt ja auch noch diesen moment aus
der schulzeit wenn man so richtig müde
waren einfach so und das manchmal so
weggeknickt ich habe das alle 20 minuten
aktion im supermarkt jeder 500 einkauf
kostet nur 1 euro geil ich war nummer
500 nicht so geil ich habe einen
kaugummi für 69 cent gekauft
willkommen in meinem leben ja ich habe
gebracht und hatte so viel fun dass mein
einkauf einfach kostenlos war und ich
nur geld und ob bekommen habe das heißt
ich habe mir curry passe kokosnussmilch
reis und zucchini für also für zwei euro
die ich bekommen habe bekommen wer
wusste dass auch dreimal am herd heißt
rückwärts auch dreimal am herd lager
regal heißt rückwärts auch lager regal
und rentner heißt rückwärts auch rentner
kennt ihr noch mehr von so was dann hast
du interessante allein dieses dreimal am
herd das stimmt halt einfach haben sie
die nutzungsbedingungen gelesen ein jahr
99 prozent nein akzeptieren sie die
nutzungsbedingungen 99 prozent jahr und
1 prozent nein und das ist die wahrheit
ich will dich sagen aber das ist
hundertprozentig einfach die wahrheit
noch nie so was durch gelesen was die
akzeptiere und dann beschweren sich
leute nachher im bus hat gerade ein
sechsjähriger aus provokationen den
ganzen bus zusammen geschrieben und die
fremde frau meinte wie alt bist du sie
wenn du sieben werden willst will ich an
einer stelle die klappe halten ansage
ich habe mich nie getraut im bus zu
reden auch immer so richtig angst vor
den sitzen
ich habe vorhin die bahnfahrt wie hast
du das hinbekommen ich habe mir ein
ticket gekauft und bin gelaufen
baker müsste
mit euren köpfen basketballspielen
vorteile wenn ich abends dusche kein
zeitdruck im bett fühlt man sich total
wohl und morgens mehr zeit der nachteil
ist allerdings die frisur sieht am
nächsten morgen aus als hätte der über
nacht ein verrücktes eichhörnchen
verzweifelt versucht eine eiche zu
verstecken das stimmt und genau so sehe
ich auch gerade aus ich werde wohl
niemals vegan leben warum ein freundes
nach drei jahren vegan und ernährung
plötzlich verstorben es war ein
autounfall aber das risiko will ich
nicht eingehen bruder verpiss dich
einfach
kennst du auch diesen moment wenn du
deine eigene stimme in einer
sprachnachricht hast und ich will dass
das deutsche überhaupt mit dir reden ja
ja ist bei mir mittlerweile ist es nicht
mehr so krass weil ich habe meine stimme
jeden tag in einem schnittprogramm höre
wenn ich hier stundenlang meine videos
schneide aber ich kenne das von so
vielen freunden wenn ich dann irgendwie
was ist von denen abspiel und diese mit
dabei sagen weißt du was der beste
beweis ist das intelligentes leben im
weltall existiert was ist der beweis
niemand hat bisher versucht kontakt mit
uns menschen aufzunehmen egal wenn
aliens mich sehen würden ich hoffe klo
sitzen eben bei was trinkt und nebenbei
mein körper ist und eine wurst in der
eindrücke alter die würden sich direkt
wieder auf bluetooth
mein freund liegt im krankenhaus weil er
ein nutella brot gegessen hat wieso
liegt er dann im krankenhaus es war mein
nutella brot oh mein gott das ist so
richtiger ahlmann humor der facebook
seite gepostet wird der pizza mann hält
mich für richtig verfressen seitdem er
mal gleichzeitig mit dem rasen vor
meiner tür stand das ist aber auch bei
dir kein wunder wenn du immer so viel
bestellt ich habe eine cola zeiten
kochen lieben und leben gelernt ich koch
jetzt mindestens einmal im monat meine
tante hat mir gerade geschrieben und
mich gefragt was ich mir zum geburtstag
wünsche und was hast du dir dann
geschrieben habe geantwortet keine
ahnung ich lasse mich gerne überraschen
um ein gott
das habe ich teilweise auch in meiner
kinder freunde ist ein was ein freundes
einladungen geburtstags in heute in der
schule war es so lustig erzählt lehrer
bildet ein satz mit dem wort spektrum
mitschüler ich hätte jetzt gerne eine
wurst mit spektrum das war
heute wo ich mir gedacht habe da keine
schmutzler über die lippen rutschen
er fragt mich auto baustelle in
deutschland schilder aufstellen fahrbahn
verengen geschwindigkeit begrenzten
maschinen hinstellen nach hause fahren
und ein jahr lang nicht mehr kommen das
ist richtig
also ich will da wirklich niemanden
angehen aber ich habe noch nie eine
baustelle in deutschland gesehen auf der
autobahn wo wirklich leute gearbeitet
haben ich fange gerade bahn wies das
lustig ein paar der bahn er
schatz ist irgendwas sieht nein
ich dachte schon das wäre was sie ganze
bahn lacht ich weiß ich warum die ganze
bahn da lacht habe ich kenne auch solche
momente warum warum können frauen nicht
einfach mal probleme richtig ansprechen
in meinen beziehungen weil ich bisher
immer das problem bei der arbeit als
kalt es gerade komplett warum an die und
stefan drei minuten vor ihrer kündigung
ligaspiel nieder spiderman wie läuft ein
leben so ich habe ein schönes haus eine
frau und zwei kinder und hall kann ich
die kennenlernen ich spiele sims mein
leben läuft scheiße und mit dieser
motivation bei der lieben freunde würde
das heutige wird jetzt auch beenden wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann einen daumen
runter video abonniert man den kanal
wenn ihr dass es mich empfehlenswert
[Musik]